what are some insights that generalize
to the training process of what it takes
to be a kgb spy right
so uh let me start with a tradecraft
so i was taught morse code that took a
while
uh i i was uh instructed in how to you
know
use a shortwave radio and to receive uh
you know the shortwave uh
transmissions with morse code
i was taught uh
uh in a encryption and decryption
algorithm manual algorithm yep
you
you might be interested that eventually
i figured out
uh at least one of the patterns uh the
the algorithm was such that
the and this was all about digits like
uh and the algorithm was such that in
the end the
uh
the digits that were used to decipher
other digits that were handed that were
sent to me via shortwave radio
there were let's say if there were a
hundred
digits there were an equal number of
ones twos threes fours five six and
seven and up until zero
and i was told that
these
algorithms these manual algorithms were
good for about 300 uses after that they
could still be
deciphered i'm assuming nowadays that
wouldn't take as much yeah with
computers for sure but there's probably
they're probably designed in a way that
you can manually
sort of uh it's efficient and convenient
to use them manually well not to
optimize cryptographic security is to
optimize it's like the balance security
and like humans being able to actually
yeah no i got to disagree it was neither
efficient nor convenient okay it took a
long time
when what was what was significantly
easier to do
uh but uh that would require you to have
spy paraphernalia with you this is
what's called a one-time pad
so you have the set of numbers yeah on
on the sheet of paper
uh
that had to be developed i had to use
iodine to make those numbers visible
those
are known to be
unbreakable unless they are used
multiple times the same the same sheet
of paper
because you know the person who encrypts
that's the same set of numbers of the
person who decrypts
and
one
one time use you cannot figure out what
the message is oh interesting but this
is the quick way to communicate from one
person to another one time one time well
one time but i had a pad with multiple
uh
paper right and uh the reason that they
gave me a manual one is because
i literally i had
only when i when i wound up in the
united states i had only one thing with
me
that uh
only a spy can have and that was a
a writing pad with uh
where the first 10 pages or so were
impregnated with a trace of a chemical
that was used for secret writing
uh but you really would have to know
what you're looking for to you know you
see this pad it was bought at a walmart
and can you explain a little a little
further what what is the chemical here
that
what are we talking about so how i i
don't understand how it's possible to
have a physical pad that does the
encryption without any computing
i how does it increase right so so no no
it doesn't it doesn't do any work you
know so
and but the uh the communication that
the encrypted communication was uh was
a set of
uh groups of five
five digits and then another five and
there's always a gap in between
uh and
so let's say if i get this radio
transmission i write them all down and
then i then i use my uh develop my
algorithm and then i do mathematics
either addition or subtraction
the resulting set of digits
had that then had a one-to-one
correlation to letters and this is an
easy way to then do the correlation yes
well that's cool that's uh and you're
saying the algorithm was not efficient
it was not oh the manual it took a long
time and and you can't make an arrow
right uh would you know where can you is
it easy to debug no you no you do it
twice
you do it twice and that's how you
change it's identical then you know
but like if it's not then then one is
right and the other is wrong don't make
mistakes no that's right and i really
didn't but anyway um so
i was i was learning that
uh i was also uh
told
that i was required to become proficient
in another language
and they gave me a choice and i picked
english
that's what was the other one oh no they
give them pick one french you know
whatever is spoken in the west got it uh
what was what was what would be second
to you would you think french because of
paris what would you what why english
english was a no-brainer because i
i was a straight aide to a student in
english without studying i like it came
so easily to me yeah so
that's why i
chose it right
uh so that was that uh then uh um
i uh
i was taught the basics of um uh counter
surveillance
you know some trickery and and uh
surveillance detection routes where you
wander around in the city
for three hours
and
determine whether you're being followed
or not
that requires you to plan the route very
well
i'll give you one example that uh that
will illustrate that
as my my favorite spot when when when i
was in moscow
i did a lot of that also
and if my favorite spot was i
it wasn't
not well traveled uh
road it went down the hill and and
curved
and at the bottom of the hill
there was a telephone booth
and when you open the door and and pick
up the telephone
you have to look back
no it wasn't like this right it wasn't a
giveaway this was normal it was natural
so yeah yeah i could see if somebody
would come walking after me you know
these kinds of things or you would uh
you know use um
public transportation uh
big buildings
uh where you
needed to use an elevator and see who's
because
surveillance
the the object of surveillance is to
never lose sight of the individual who
you're surveilling because at that point
you may miss the window where he does
something that that you're looking for
so somebody
always has to come close right did you
have to also study
surveillance no sony counter
surveillance
and what helped me in in all my training
uh you know i would
be would have a competition with the
folks that were coming that were
following me
and me
and i beat them every time
uh they were at a disadvantage because
one of them always had to be close and
and if you saw the same face twice you
know
that you were being followed and i had a
very very good uh memory for for faces
so basically figure out a fixed route
and then a fixed route that allows you
to uh
survey the area and then record the
faces you've seen inside your mind
and if uh you see multiple times a
single face that's that's a bad sign and
they they could they could uh
you use uh different clothes
yeah uh what they didn't have
was face masks yeah the cia does
nowadays
they can give you a different face
within seconds
oh my god yeah
so
[Laughter]
i mean again you talk about paranoia
is that part of the is that a big part
of the job
uh counter surveillance like being
constantly paranoid that you're being
watched yeah i was supposed isn't that
quite stressful so is that is that one
of the is that actually an effective way
to operate uh no but it sort of becomes
a routine uh i was told to do it uh
while in the u.s uh once a month
and uh okay it's like a cleaning out oh
not every day no no no no no once a
month or
before i would say mail a letter with
secret writing so i was sure that you
know nobody saw me put an envelope into
a
postbox so this is one of the tools in
your toolbox so there's morse code
there's yes the decryption and
encryption there's the kind of
surveillance photography
photography um making making micro dots
you know what a micro dot is
well that's uh that's uh
you use
you you take a photograph
and you use a microscope in reverse
and make
that photograph
really small
so small that it's like the
the
head of a pin
that can be used to uh
hide under a postage stamp
yeah
in reality i knew how to make them
but in reality they
they never asked me to to make use of
that technique so it's a sort of an
encryption mechanism for photographs
yeah so what we do nowadays is an embed
code in
in uh pdfs and stuff like that right
yep beautiful okay all right so that
that was a learning a training process
both in the physical space
algorithmically
is there other things oh you bet
interestingly enough the
i was
the first book i was given to read was
the history of this uh these uh
communist party of the soviet union
also understand yeah that's interesting
because you said you had to read western
literature yeah that too how much how
much reading
so history how much history of politics
geopolitics
not culture
but they made me read that document uh
other than that
i wasn't supposed to study the soviet
union i wasn't supposed and that was not
and i didn't when they sent me to moscow
it wasn't to learn russia russian right
it was to learn english
the the second document they gave me was
the the constitution of west germany
and then i got lots of magazines and
stuff like that uh as i told you i was
also told to
uh
watch west german television which i
which i uh
embraced with a vengeance because it was
better than east german
so i would get up in the morning and
have a little breakfast and watch
the german version of sesame street
and that that that helps you um that
helps you get an understanding of the
culture if you have to do any kind of
uh interaction yes kind of spying then
you have to be and be able to
effectively integrate well you also have
to know like in and that would have been
easier
uh
if they had sent me to west germany you
know all the soccer teams you know stuff
that everybody knows when i came to the
us i knew very little stuff that
everybody knows that's why i had to be
very cautious and you know take it in
over time anyway uh and the the last
thing i want to mention is uh
they i was
strongly encouraged to
uh expand my
my cultural education in other words
go to visit museums uh go to the theater
uh not so much movies uh opera
read
read books you know from all kinds of
authors
uh that was important to them and once a
month i had to write a report what i did
but
the interesting thing there was not a
there was no curriculum there was no
agenda there were no check marks it was
all ad hoc you know now you do this and
then you do that
uh
and uh
and a lot of this also they relied on my
initiative again i mean that's part of
the evaluation too you bet
uh are you able to have creative it's
interesting that they're like developing
a james bond type of character here
which is
what's the reason to go to the opera
as you become yes cultured in a certain
kind of way where perhaps that makes you
um more charming more charismatic in
terms of your ability to integrate
yourself in different situations you
were absolutely right
i
i was
i was uh
when i came to the u.s
after about
two years roughly
i was cultured enough to
not
uh
make a bad impression at it at a
diplomatic sorry in washington dc i
mingled freely yes all right
and and and so the whole idea was for me
to sort of reach into the upper
realms of society
where
the targets would be juicier than you
know the worker bees
you